je veux aussi être clair je ne rendrai
pas la vaccination obligatoire
ça c'était le 24 novembre 2020 et
aujourd'hui l'académie de médecine
recommande d'envisager l'obligation
vaccinale avec l'instauration d'une
obligation vaccinale pour certains pays
est une incitation constante à se faire
vacciner
c'est à se demander si la vaccination
contre le coc u19 ne serait plus
seulement recommandée et indirectement
obligatoires alors peut-on rendre cette
vaccination obligatoire et sur quels
fondements des réponses dans facture
[Musique]
actuellement le vaccin contre le coc u19
n'est donc pas obligatoire mais les
français sont fortement encouragés à
aller se faire vacciner
cette incitation se fait sentir d'une
part à travers les prises de parole des
différents membres du gouvernement vous
êtes genre à vous faire vacciner à vous
faire accès à tous les vaccins mais
surtout à travers l'instauration d'un
passeport vaccinale dans le carnet de
rappel numérique et d'impasses
sanitaires européennes y aura à la fois
le fait que vous êtes vacciné et le fait
que vous avez des tests par le vaccin
n'est pas obligatoire parce que impasse
anita fonctionne avec un test pcr de
moins trois jours donc il ya toujours
une alternative mais en tout cas c'est
une forte incitation puisque tout est
fait pour nous encourager à lennon faire
vacciner pourquoi ne pas le rendre
obligatoire comme les onze vaccins pour
les admissions à l'école par exemple
déjà parce que le vaccin contre kaulitz
et un vaccin un nouveau on manque de
recul pour le moment la stratégie la
plus utile ccc de ne pas le rendre
obligatoire parce qu'il ya cette
adhésion
en effet d'après une étude menée par
kate cnc pour le journal du dimanche
69% des français souhaiteraient se faire
vacciner mais pourrait-on obligée
légalement les 31 % restants moi je ne
vois pas comment on va pouvoir créer une
sanction concrète pour la personne qui
choisirait même pas se faire vacciner si
cette vaccination devient obligatoire
on ferait quoi une amende ça voudrait
dire créer tout un arsenal juridique
autour du d'un toit finalement de santé
publique a mon avis c'est impossible à
mettre en place
la seule sanction si cette sanction
indirects d'empêcher l'accès à certains
espaces fermés
si vous ne pouvez pas justifier de votre
passeport vaccinale donc concrètement on
ne peut pas obliger les français à aller
se faire vacciner contre colline 19 mai
pourtant l'obligation vaccinale a déjà
été appliquée en france dans les années
soixante dix vous aviez la diphtérie la
polio qui était très compliquée à
maîtriser c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a imposé la vaccination aux jeunes
enfants qui a été initiée par le mois de
décembre 2017 et donc on a des
vaccinations obligatoires pour les 115
plus attendre c'est le même principe
pour tous les vaccins c'est à dire qu'on
n'impose pas un vaccin s'il n'y a pas
une difficulté d'épidémie à traiter de
maladies graves à éviter le caniveau
mais 19 il s'agit bien d'une épidémie le
vaccin pourrait être imposée sauf que
les limites à cette obligation c'est que
ça pourrait accélérer la défiance
vis-à-vis du vaccin mais n'oublions pas
que 69% des français souhaiteraient se
faire vacciner
je pense que si on avait une politique
un peu plus coercitive sur sur le vaccin
ça pour être contre-productif on est
dans un contexte où la demande est bien
supérieure à l'offre
on est tous à chercher des rendez vous
sur survie de mathod sur d'autolib
effectivement pendant plusieurs semaines
il a été très très très compliqué de
trouver en traîneau de vaccination
d'autant plus que la vaccination
obligatoire impose aussi à l'état
d'avoir
deux doses disponibles que le citoyen
sur le territoire des doses qui nous
savons pas toujours été au rendez vous
l'enjeu c'est plutôt profité de deux
sous serre qu'un peu vertueux qui fait
que au rythme actuel on devrait
atteindre un objectif en rendant la
vaccination obligatoire on va se
confronter à un débat avec les anti
vaccins qu'ils ont une part de la
population making part quand même assez
faible ministre à des gens un vaccin
bidouiller vous savez comment sont les
français
il suffit de leur dire que quelque chose
est obligatoire pour trouver quelque
chose de louche derrière et puis ça
pourrait freiner l'adhésion mais qu'il y
ait une obligation ou pas le
gouvernement intensifier le rythme avec
l'ouverture de la vaccination à tous les
adultes dans le pays car il semblerait
que la vaccination soit la porte de
sortie la plus plausible de cette
épidémie
cette étude menée par l'institut pasteur
démontre qu'il faudrait que 90 % des
adultes soient vaccinés au 1er septembre
pour espérer un retour à la vie normale
à la rentrée la vaccination c'est le
chemin le plus court pour arriver à fin
de la crise
[Musique]
non